hello everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio fantastic Fest
2023 right now I get to talk to someone
who I've been dying to talk to since I
saw the movie fixation which you should
all like hit social media hit the
internet tell the world you want to see
that movie because it's beautifully shot
as is the creator by cinematographer or
Oren software congratulations on
everything you've accomplished thus far
and thank you you're getting all the
praise you deserve thank you so much
that's very sweet you've been very kind
and supportive and I I appreciate it uh
and uh yeah I'm excited to chat been
excited to chat with you I'm very
excited so we obviously have to talk
about the Creator but I do want our
audience to get to know you a little
better first and I love asking this in
terms of starting uh one's uh journey in
the industry what was the the movie you
saw the personal experience you had
person you met you name it that first
inspired you to say I need to get into
the film industry well the story starts
from before I have fully formed memories
but I have like a core memory of Yoda
wiggling around in the Hut on an Empire
Strikes Back like wiggling his little
puppet butt and like that image is
seared in my brain and I think I must
have seen that when I was two or three
at daycare like somebody put on Empire
Strikes Back where it was on TV like on
TBS or something and and I just soaked
it in and then immediately became
obsessed with Star Wars and uh sought
out the the original films my uncle had
a LaserDisc player I watched them on
LaserDisc the special editions came out
in 97 and that was a seminal moment
um so yeah Big Star Wars kid big
dinosaur kid Jurassic Park was huge the
right answer the right answer was huge
uh yeah massive massively important
movie uh and then so when the special
editions came out
the VHS box set which I still have caked
in dust somewhere and I can't watch it
um but uh it came with a CD-ROM that was
an interactive behind the scenes of the
making of Star Wars and it has all the
footage we've seen subsequently there's
like Empire of dreams I think it's
called the documentary that was on the
DVD later yeah
um and uh yeah so it's all using the
same materials and it's all the initial
like industrial Light and magic stuff
the shots of the green screens the ships
the models that was switch number one
and then switch number two that kind of
closed the circuit was Lord of the Rings
special editions the pet the appendices
uh on the special edition box sets I
inhaled those and this was now middle
school high school so I was a little
older and a little bit more like oh I'm
seriously like I really I don't just
love movies I actually want to make them
I I see the process of making them that
looks cool I want to be a part of that
um and yeah I was always into visual art
I was painting and drawing as a kid and
I picked up photography and my friends
and I would make silly movies on
camcorders
um in middle school so it all ended up
funneling into cinematography and
filmmaking so many yeah so many
follow-up questions because you made
those silly movies what were those
movies about and do you find yourself
still drawn to those kinds of stories
now as a professional cinematographer
somewhat yes
um I mean one of them was about a uh
briefcase Heist and it was a like a
crazy whack visual comedy we did all
these gags like we we made a um a
stuffed person like out of just clothes
and and stuffing and and cotton and one
of the gags was that uh as the
characters are sort of escaping from one
another one of them accidentally falls
off of a 20th story balcony so you know
we filmed the first part of it with our
actor just sort of pretending to go over
and we cut to a shot from the street and
we dropped the Dummy from the balcony 20
stories down onto the ground uh and I
still have a copy of that film somewhere
uh scanned in low resolution from you
know
that should be a DVD bonus feature on
the Creator and it should be like look
at where I started and look at where I
am now it would be one of the saddest
versions of that example I
not that I'm make movies anymore but my
very first assignment in grad school and
directing class was one of like the
saddest things in the world and at the
end it like won worse the worst shorter
or something in the whole time why did
they even have a price for Worse yes
better we do get better I think it was
all it was done to like well reflect how
one could grow in a program because if
you watch my first and last like it
shows the value of something like that
that's good that's good yeah I can see
the value in that but I appreciated that
yeah yeah no I think it was kind of
always drawn to genre stuff
um heists and and you know um uh I don't
know robberies and and westerns and we
did like a fantasy film in high school
that was this whole like this guy steals
the the
Scythe from death and it was I mean it
sounds insane when I describe it because
it was and it was like a high school
movie so it was very low quality and and
uh yeah but yeah those were the early
Explorations for sure and I think
there's a direct line from there to now
so somehow you decide you want to be a
professional cinematographer at that
point when you made that decision what
did you think was step one to making
that dream a reality and now having done
it would you give that first step as a
recommendation to somebody who wants to
fall in your footsteps great question
um I mean I think first step for me was
just starting to educate myself and I
lived in Israel at the time so I was
like about as far from this as one could
be certainly as far from Hollywood and
Los Angeles and and the American film
industry but kind of always dreaming
about it
um and I grew up in the states as a kid
so I always had sort of one foot in both
cultures and I obviously I I English is
my first language
um I'm not in here with an Israeli
accent or anything but so I think that
helped me keep my mind a little bit on
like I'll go back to America and work in
movies one day
um but yeah so while over there
um we had a filmmaking class in high
school which was very special and I'm
very lucky I wish yeah I know very very
very fortunate I mean it was Scrappy
this was 2003 we were shooting on
literally VHS like a VHS camera with the
full-size tape uh on which the some of
these movies that I just described were
filmed and one thing I always remember
from that and eventually we moved to
mini DV
I was like why doesn't this look like
movies like why doesn't this look like
shallow depth of fields Cinema lenses
like I didn't know anything about
sensors chip size sensor size digital
cameras versus fill 35 millimeter film I
didn't know any of that so I had to
learn and um there were a few like very
seminal books that I think every
aspiring cinematographer eventually
stumbles upon there's like the five C's
of cinematography and um Blaine Brown's
book that's just called cinematography
and uh a few others so that was the
beginning and watching DVD extras yes a
lot of great stuff in the DVD extras and
this is all pre-youtube like this so
none of the resources that are available
now were available I think it's a lot
easier to self-educate now but at the
time it was you had to look yeah yeah
and then the second step was going to
film school which
um so I went to NYU I did good choice
good choice no it was great it was great
I mean would I recommend it it's it's an
open question because it was great for
me like it was very important because I
was moving from a a different country
halfway across the world I didn't know
anybody I didn't know anybody in America
like I had to start from scratch
um and I thought that that would be the
best place the best way to do it and it
was because you meet so many people and
like all my good friends are from NYU
and all my closest buddies and and
people that I work with so like it was
really important yeah but also very
expensive
and I don't necessarily think it's like
a need I always talk about that with
Film School like one of the questions
that I have a habit of asking just to
like further emphasize that it could be
the right path for some but not for
others is what is something you learned
in that program that you still find
yourself using all the time today but
then also can you name something that
all the schooling in the world never
would have taught you when you hit your
first professional set yeah yeah I mean
that's definitely the case at NYU like
uh well we had one Professor especially
all shout out Gordon arkenberg he taught
a class called the science of
cinematography that just blew our minds
uh and it was all about physics and
Optics and lensing and light Spectra and
like just mind-blowing stuff that I
think is actually very important for
cinematography and that's like the
perfect example of something you learn
in a classroom setting that if I was
just sitting in front of a physics book
by myself I would close it like I'm like
I do not need to know any of this stuff
but you kind of do so it's um that class
was very seminal and his influence I
think is felt from like every
cinematographer who's gone to NYU knows
Gordon took his class and talks about
that class
um and then I think also film history
like I think
I encounter a lot of younger DPS who
don't watch movies or don't watch a ton
of movies and I'm always like what do
you what do you how do you how do you
talk to directors because directors
speak movie yeah directors all watch a
ton of movies and they know all the
references and they reference specific
movies and shots and film language and
if you don't speak that language I'm
like I don't know how you work with a
director especially a narrative maybe
it's different commercials and music
videos but
um which I do as well but uh yeah so
just studying film history it's like
huge and obviously film school is just a
great people can do it on their own you
have Criterion Channel you got websites
you got blah I mean there's so many
things just go down the Sight and Sound
lists and start from number one and go
down to 100 but um I get it like it's
hard sometimes to find the time and and
also to have the analytical mind yeah to
understand film language and analyze it
and study it so that was really great
but um the one thing you don't get in
school is just onset experience and so
that was really the thing that you don't
learn it's especially on professional
sets well I mean we would shoot a lot of
student films but there's only so much
you learn on student film I mean you
learn really you learn how to make a
student film very well yes on student
film sets but it doesn't always
translate to professional shoots but I
was very lucky I met Reed Murano a
sophomore year so good yeah and she's an
uh alumni program together at the same
time she's
12 or more years older older than me so
she did the program earlier in the 2000s
but she's she's an uh alumnus so she
came back to speak and this was before
famous read Murano this was like Indie
Sundance to read Miranda I'm like
picturing the shot of hers of Olivia
Wilde and metal and walking through
through Times Square and ever since I've
seen that shot I'm like you are a name
that I will always look out for my
favorite shot of read is when she shot
um I forget the name of the film little
bird I think or little birds
sounds terrible that I'm messing it up
but she was seven months pregnant and on
hand hold operating a 35 millimeter
camera and she's got her eye in the
eyepiece and her hands resting on her
belly and you see that and you're like
you were just one of those badass people
I've ever met so anyway she came to
speak at NYU and I was very fortunate uh
well it was me and one other kid we knew
who she was
um because we were well studied in
cinema and then we went and talked to
her after the class and she said uh hey
yeah I'm shooting this movie Kill Your
Darlings like do you want to come help
out on set so I did three movies with
her as a as a camera PA like an intern
and that was my first professional set
exposure uh and now one can argue NYU is
the reason that connection happened
which it was that's the thing it's the
community and connecting the dots it was
it was but
um subsequently you know I'm skipping
ahead a little bit but I met Greg Fraser
and that all happened outside of that
framework best in the business I have
been obsessed with the best work for a
long time now me too
as you could probably imagine so he's
been a huge influence and I've stolen a
lot from Greg over the years how did you
meet him we met at the ASC Awards like
completely randomly well actually before
that we had uh we were damning on
Instagram
which is just to say that did you DM him
definitely okay yeah or maybe he saw
like a short you made and felt mistake
he might have you know what I don't
exactly remember maybe maybe I should
tell myself that that's right because I
am curious like when you when you want
to reach out to someone you admire like
that how do you even begin that
conversation or build the courage to
send the message you know that's the
thing is I mean I think that's the
israelian me there's like a little bit
of khutzpah for sure that is like oh no
I don't know what's the problem like I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna reach out I
mean I'm not even overthinking it I'm
just like why wouldn't I you know this
is this is what this platform is so so
great for is like Instagram's here we
have access to all these people like use
it and I encourage people to reach out
to me all the time I'll tell people like
DM me if any questions you have email
like whatever you have and people do and
I'm I'm always more than happy to answer
any and give back in that way because in
the world yeah because I just got really
lucky with my mentorships and I'm like I
gotta I gotta give it back gotta pay it
forward I was just talking to Sun Kang
who just directed his first feature and
he was busy singing Robert Rodriguez and
Walter Hill's Praises because they're so
they're so open with all of their
knowledge they're like sitting there
eager to share it just because by
sharing it we make films better in the
future yeah 100 another great book that
I read in high school by the way Rebel
Without a crew Robert Rodriguez he's
written a few books about Indie
filmmaking so yeah I just soaked all
those up what is the other one yeah
Raging Bulls uh what is it easy Riders
and Raging Bulls that's another good
book oh what I would what I would do to
like see his space Oh my God here in
Austin it's here right yeah it's like
can we go
can he make us some pizza DM him maybe
he'll say yes not a bad idea I'll do it
I'll do it so we we brought up uh we
brought up Greg can you maybe give us a
specific example of a technique that
Greg taught you that we could see
influencing your own work whether it's
on the Creator or anything you've made
thus far I think it's more a philosophy
um Greg I think has always talked about
and I've always responded to his use of
single Source lighting
and there's some quote that from an old
interview of his that just was lodged in
my brain for years which was he's like
when I walk into a space a location the
first question that I ask myself is can
I shoot this scene without any lights
like is this gonna is this giving me
enough as it is to just set up the
camera and start shooting and if the
answer is yes then then I'm gonna do it
that way like there's no need to add and
to Guild the Lily or put um uh sprinkles
on top of ice cream as he also puts it
it's like it's too sweet when you're
adding things that that's it's already
good
um and then if you do need add a light
then you start to ask yourself like can
I do this with one light
and then you just slowly build it out
from there but it's always starting from
the source of
single Source lighting available
lighting natural light and embracing
that and that's something that's always
been very omnipresent in his work and
something that I've always responded to
um I mean somewhere along this journey I
also picked up still photography so I'm
taking a lot of Stills a lot of street
photography over many many years like
during travels and all that and um I
don't do studio photography like
lighting or anything like that it's
purely just travel street photography
from the hip natural light so I think
that also has like ingrained itself in
me for sure this is definitely gonna
come up when we start to talk about how
you guys shot the Creator before it all
connects like I love reading about how
you know like light the crew and the
gear was and how you're able to move and
be more fluid with everything because of
it but before I even get there so Greg
was meant to shoot the Creator yes Dune
two came up and he had to step step out
and he recommended you for the job when
you found out and were offered this
position was it like yeah no brainer I'm
ready to make this leap to a major
Studio film or was there any nerves or
apprehension or maybe burning questions
you wanted Greg to answer to make sure
you felt comfortable yes well uh many
thoughts were going through my head the
first one was yeah absolutely and it's
actually kind of funny Greg at first
when he pictured me was like I don't
know if this is going to interest you
it's it's I know it's very he's like
this is a very weird pitch the way we're
setting this up is very unorthodox and
and I'm gonna explain it all because he
had been sort of developing this
methodology with Gareth over a couple
years and planning about how to shoot
the film and and then in the my mind I'm
like I don't even know why you would
start with that like of course I'm gonna
say yes to whatever you're about to say
to me
so like uh you know it's it's very
considerate I I appreciate that he's
he's that kind of person that that
thinks about that stuff but I was like
of course it's a no-brainer but I did
have many questions
um most of which didn't have answers yet
which then became part of the like I
just have to let go of the anxieties and
the unknowns of this and just like jump
in can you give us an example of a
question you had that didn't have an
answer then but you discovered the
answer to along the way it wasn't clear
when he pitched the project to me and
this was before official pre-production
started like the specific Logistics of
who's gonna do the costuming like who's
gonna we had all the basically every
aspect of this film is unorthodox yes so
one one unorthodox aspect was the
costuming which some people haven't a
lot of people haven't talked about yet
but someone should reach out to uh
Jeremy Hannah the costume designer
um and he works at WETA or he he worked
at wada workshop and has since left um
to work on other projects but he's down
in New Zealand
um also a young guy I met him at the
premiere the or sorry the special
screening the other week uh amazing like
lovely guy never step foot on set but he
designed all the costumes with Gareth
what a workshop fabricated them and then
shipped them to Thailand so when I came
on board the project those were already
well into production and I saw all the
images all the the concept art the
designs of the costumes the look of them
and the physical props the photos they
took so I was like oh wow I mean this
looks incredible and talk about another
connection to Lord of the Rings the
special features the minute you find out
like oh what a workshop made the props
and costumes for this and like that's
that's just as crazy as industrial Light
Magic doing the visual visual effects
and somehow I'm involved in this like
it's nuts but anyway we had the costumes
and then I was like okay who's
um putting them on the actors like who's
the costume designers in New Zealand
like what what is what's the what is the
actual logistical process here of like
how this is going to go especially
because how it was described to me was
like you're gonna be driving around
Thailand in a van
and hopping out on the side of the road
and like shooting a scene in a village
and then hopping back in the van like
going to the next place
which is sort of accurate to how it
ended up being but it was just a bit of
a bigger foot there were like 100 Vans
it wasn't just one van there was a lot
there was actually a big um production
footprint that supported the film but
um I don't think I certainly and I don't
think even Greg knew
what that would look like when before we
actually started pre-production the hard
prep in Thailand but by the time we got
there it became very apparent how
everything was going to work and so all
that anxiety and all the all that
question all that questioning went away
and I think part of that was like coming
from indie films
you feel like you always have to ask
those questions like okay but like how
are we going to accomplish this and how
are we going to accomplish that but the
biggest thing I learned right away was
like you're in a different League now
people have got this people have thought
about this stuff and you don't have to
worry about it you don't have to worry
about that stuff the scheduling I could
just focus on what I need to do and that
was like a breath of fresh air you are
in a different league with this film but
one of the most refreshing things about
this production to me is that it's a big
it's a big budget Studio film but one
that doesn't overspend unnecessarily yes
can you name something about the way you
shot this movie that more big budget
films should consider using because it
is more cost effective but it still
produces a killer image totally I mean I
think the well first off obviously
visually in terms of lighting camera
work lensing we made a ton of decisions
that were all
initially I mean first and foremost
designed to create an immersive and
um uh believable and tactile experience
for the audience but also embracing
prosumer equipment and also things that
allowed us to have that smaller
footprint and create that look now am I
going to sit here and say like well
every shoot should just use prosumer
equipment not necessarily but I think
it's more the ethos and like the thought
of starting from minimalism and it goes
back to that Greg quote it's like can I
do this with nothing or with just what I
have there's a lot of just in case
thinking on big budget filmmaking where
you're like well let's just have all
this stuff and all this crew and all
this equipment just in case but for us
it was really more about paring it down
and saying like no no we we're going to
narrow this down to just what we need uh
in order to accomplish this look and it
meant we shot on one lens we shot on one
focal length we didn't carry a whole
lens set
um we shot on this small camera bodies
not a big footprint we shot on
um we expanded the scope of the
production when we needed to uh and like
we had some night scenes that those do
require more lighting and there's some
sequences where you use the bigger crane
but we only we they played that stuff so
we wouldn't actually just carry it all
around with us it was it just required
more planning
um I think the biggest thing though is
just the Innovative visual effects
approach like that the the reverse
engineering of it which Gareth has
talked about and explained um is I think
the key to unlocking this this budget
level and it's the same thing like it
requires
extra planning and extra thought and
keeping your production designer into
post and just rethinking how you're
approaching design but the end result is
um Incredible cost savings but also like
even more tactile and immersive
um
visuals but uh I mean one example that I
can give about the sort of overall
approach uh is
there's a shot in the movie that is also
in the trailers and it's a shot of an
ambulance flipping over from the inside
and uh and it's not a spoiler giveaway
because it is in the trailer and so
when usually when you read a shot like
that in a script if you're for example
the production designer and not to even
get into the lighting which I'll get
into uh you know you read that you're
like okay so or or you're the stunt
coordinator you're like all right so
we're gonna have to build like a custom
ambulance interior set put it on a
gimbal put it on a stage have it be able
to roll in that way and put the stunt
actors in there rig them up
uh all just to get this one little shot
and Gareth immediately just goes no no
no no we're not we're not doing that
we have a real ambulance that we're
filming our exterior shots of the
driving of the the driving footage of
the ambulance on and our Interiors of um
the characters that are in it
all we need for this shot is it's it's
less than a second and we just need to
give the impression of the ambulance
flipping over so we did it in the old
school Star Trek way ambulance is parked
outside so we don't need to light it
it's getting natural daylight
um the camera is looking through the
back and we tented the back so that it
didn't look like there was light coming
in uh and then uh we did a three two one
countdown and Gareth rolls the camera 90
degrees sideways and the actors throw
themselves into the air and the props
team are throwing some medical supplies
in in after them uh and papers flying
around and that's the shot in the movie
so it's it's it's less like one specific
thing because that's one of like dozens
of examples of just embracing that
mentality and just saying like that's
all we need you know like what's what's
the quick Scrappy way to do this and I
think that that just blew my mind and
way more big Productions could and
should like Embrace that kind of
thinking and that kind of filmmaking
it's like very pure filmmaking you know
never in a million years would I have
guessed you you completed that shot that
way oh yeah yeah yeah there's other
stuff people haven't tapped into and we
haven't talked about yet but there's
like we used a lot of projectors for
stuff like just from Amazon like cheap
projectors that just plugged into a
laptop uh for some driving shots and for
some of the stuff on Nomad there's like
really Lo-Fi Scrappy solutions to things
that would normally take like a lot of
resources and I think that's that's what
makes the difference is like that
approach and that you know I just I love
that stuff like that is that goes back
to the movies I was making in high
school it was just like the silly
everything about I'm glad we started
where we did with this conversation
because it does feel like you held tight
to what inspired you from the very very
beginning and now we can see we can see
it reflected in your work but also that
same enthusiasm for similar things still
there powering everything yeah
absolutely and Gareth still has that
yeah you know Gareth whatever 10 or
however many years older than I am he is
12. and he still has that passion and
he's still just a kid making movies with
his friends like and on an 80 million
dollar movie it's like it's that makes
all the difference is having you here
all day
I got time my flight's not till later no
one gave me like an evil eye yet I want
to go back to to Gareth because I know
he likes to operate sometimes he's got
clearly is a very unique way of making
his films what is something about him
and the way he operates on set and
collaborates with his cinematographer
that is purely him unique to him well he
operated pretty much this whole movie
so um that was a big part of the the
initial design of how we were going to
make the film was to empower him to be
spontaneous and reactive in real time to
things that were happening we're always
fishing for those moments of genuine you
know like the things that are unplanned
and because those end up resulting in
like the most interesting scenes or
moments or little details so it was all
about giving him and the actors the
space to explore and discover and that
was a big part of how we we wanted to to
shoot the film we lit the film based
around that idea and and it was more
about lighting a space Greg has a great
analogy where he he talks about like
it's like painting a house
most of the work goes to you know
putting up the tape and moving the
furniture and kind of mixing your paints
and kind of getting everything ready and
once you've done all that work which we
did in pre-production with a lot of
planning and thought
um once you actually get on set it's
like the last 20 is just painting and
you just go for it and you have the
freedom to paint you can start over here
you can start over here like if you've
done the prep right you can start
painting whichever wall you want uh and
that's how we designed the lighting of
the film as well was it was like
lighting the space and lighting the
environments and creating basically like
a little playground for Gareth and the
actors to to play with so Gareth
operated
Garrett's a great operator and and this
wouldn't have worked if he wasn't and
and this is also why this method would
not necessarily work with every other
director because
um it's you have to have a director
who's good at operating it has a good
eye and Gareth is um he just has good
taste his great taste he knows where to
find the good lighting he knows that if
lighting is coming from this direction
like from a window that if you come
around to the other side you're going to
get the nice fall off and the nice
contrast like you don't need to tell him
he knows he instinctually finds those
angles and those situations and he also
has this very like
spielbergy way of
coming up with shots it's like very
simple tricks when you actually break it
down but it's all about like
interaction between foreground and
background always having foreground
depth as well as background depth layers
of the shot coming starting on something
in the close-up and then coming off of
that and revealing something else or
following a character from one shot to
another shot and making those
connections then he has he has like that
instinct that and that's that film
language like he's just steeped in film
language and he just knows it
instinctually and it makes for like
great shots like very kinetic visual
style that he just comes up with like
you don't have to force it you don't
have to overthink it it's very gut gut
reaction and so it's just a pleasure to
work with that I've always been a big
believer that any filmmaker no matter
what your role is on a Film Production
can benefit from having a clear
understanding of what the other jobs on
a film set are and it seems like he's
the kind of person who not only has a
good understanding of the other
positions on a film crew but like a good
understanding of how to best support
their work as well and that is so vital
to something like this in particular
coming together and feeling real he's a
very unique director I mean I certainly
have not worked with anybody even
remotely close to this and I don't know
if I ever will unless unless he calls me
again for whatever his next film is
after he takes a long and much needed
vacation somewhere he has very much
earned it and I think he's been
fantasizing about it for a couple years
but uh he'll get he'll get the vacation
but yeah I mean he you know he's the
kind of director who he'll sit in the
van on the way to set designing a
graphic logo that's going to appear in
the background
um somewhere and he just does it himself
because he's like oh the the graphics
department they already have their hands
full like they got all this other stuff
they're working on nobody's thinking
about this tiny little logo but me so
like I'm just gonna do it and he has a
background in graphic design and he has
a background of visual we saw with his
photography he gets it all yeah all of
it all of it so but then he's not
um he's very collaborative so that's
what makes it work is that he can do
everyone's job but he he doesn't want to
and I mean he knows that he can't
physically do everybody's job because
it's you have to do it all at the same
time it's not possible
um and so he has such a Clear Vision and
such a clear understanding of what
everyone does but what he does is he
brings you in and he brings you into his
world and his mentality and his thought
process and and and and lifts you up and
says like
I want your Artistry in this and I want
you to understand what I'm going for
here and pick up on what I'm putting
down so that you can run with it and my
whole goal on set was like I he's
dealing with so much there's he was a
producer on the project he's operating
the camera he's directing the actors I
was like I don't want to bother him like
I if I can go a whole day without
talking to Gareth except like saying hi
to him in the morning that was a great
day because that means that that mind
meld that we worked on during prep and
with Greg and everybody worked and that
I understood what Gareth likes and what
he wants and what he needs and that we
gave him what he needed uh and empowered
him to create and to explore and to find
the the shots and moments for one reason
or another can you pinpoint the day
where the Mind meld needed on the spot
adjustment and whatever you were working
on called for the most collaboration on
the day between you and Gareth
um I I don't want to sit here and rack
my brain thinking of a specific example
because there's so many but it was
really just a constant dance between the
two of us like the way we designed the
lighting approach for the film was
that it would be flexible enough to
react to whatever Gareth was doing
spontaneously with the camera so there
were a few techniques that we employed
in order to do that one of them was just
planting a few different lights around
and then I would sit at the monitor with
my gaffer pitai so it was a Thai bass
gaffer bet from Bangkok
um who's also a DP excellent DP
and we would watch what Gareth is doing
and then just react in real time so like
if he starts to drift over to look in
another direction we have dimmers on all
the lights and we could just dim down
the light that now is not looking so
great and is looking a little bit flat
and Gareth doesn't even notice he
shouldn't notice that we're adjusting
the lighting in that way we also had our
best electric Nancy
um rocking a uh LED light on a boom pole
so that was the get out of jail free
card that she was always on standby with
that thing and it was always ready and
whenever we just needed a little extra
like Garrett's up in a shot and we're
like we just need a little extra boost
or a little extra wrap of the light like
just to make it perfect we would call
her in we're all on on wireless comms
and then she would just sneak in very
quietly and and you know Gareth would
maybe feel it and she had uh we put an
iPhone on her arm like with a workout
armband and she was able to watch to see
the shot in real time like what Gareth
was filming so she could find her
perfect position and we would talk her
into it
um so yeah like it was every day it was
that dance was we were reacting to what
Gareth was doing and gareth's reacting
to what we're doing and how we lit a
space so it was this mutual thing but we
wouldn't have to over communicate about
it because it was just planned that way
and we would talk about we would talk
about these things on the scouts so like
all this was already figured out by the
time we would show up we would come back
to a location after two months having
scouted it and been like oh we know what
we're doing here we already talked about
this we're going to do this this this
and this and just comes together pretty
quickly and we also we had Gareth miked
up this was the other thing I've never
seen uh anyone do before but we had it
Gareth on on a microphone so he was on a
wireless mic that was picking up his
monologue
and we all had him in our ear the whole
crew the the A.D the other department
heads everything so whenever he needed
something or would call out or he would
be able to say like I'm gonna drift over
here and you know frame up this other
thing so we now we know where he's going
to go
um or he would say like oh I'm gonna I'm
gonna start tilted up here and then
we're gonna add a ship over there and
tilt down into the shot and we'll come
up with that we'll add that later like
he's giving himself VFX notes for later
for the monologue and then the best
thing about it is he does sound effects
so so so we're you know set up in an
action scene and then he's like
doing all the sound effects
um which is very funny and
um endearing but actually serve as a
purpose because it's about pacing so
it's about like the timing of certain
shots he's basically sound designing the
movie in his head like while we're
shooting it and editing I mean to be a
bonus like I can't as you started to
explain it I pictured or or heard in my
head like the the mic'd up thing that
they do with uh with football players
and like I like I want a clip of this
but with Gareth running through a
particular shot now we absolutely said
onset that we should do an alternate
sound mix that only uses gareth's sound
effects for the DVD or the Blu-ray
um and uh I really hope they follow
through with that I would watch this in
a heartbeat all right very entertaining
I'm going to end with two big broad
questions they're difficult questions
because I'm gonna make you specify
particular shots in the film but the
first one of all of the incredible work
you deliver in this movie which
particular shot was the most difficult
to accomplish whether it's because it
needed workshopping or because of some
sort of technical feat that you've never
tried before the most difficult sequence
in the film is the tank battle
um and it's it's hard to break it down
into individual shots because they were
all it was all difficult but uh yeah
that was the most remote location the
most physically difficult the the the
crummiest hotel you know like everything
about it was hard it was the uh and and
not that I'm complaining about you know
being flown around the world and put up
in hotels but some of them were very
nice and some of them were not so nice
uh but yeah it's a very remote part of
Thailand beautiful I mean just stunning
like especially in the morning the sun
would come up over the river there's
mountains in the background that are
actually Myanmar we're on the border and
there's this town that straddles a river
with this bridge and it's all that
stuff's there like all that stuff was
practical
um and and just found and we built we
actually built the whole sequence around
it so that scene was storyboarded but um
it was actually storyboarded to a
different location and we initially
planned on shooting it in Cambodia in
Siem Reap on in the floating village but
because of kovid and everything it we
did not end up um we were not able to
shoot in in Cambodia which was very sad
we scouted it which was incredible uh
and that's another story but um yeah so
we we sort of had to Pivot away from the
initial we had done a lot of planning
and we had to we had to Pivot on the Fly
which was the nature of of this film
um and re-skin the sequence onto this
new location
so we hadn't scouted it we or or we
hadn't counted it in advance we had a
few days set aside for scouting before
we started filming and we went all
around the town looked at all the angles
where the town looked good where the
village had the best angles what time of
day and basically just built out the
sequence like as we were going and then
the shoot is like I was describing
before it's this very spontaneous loose
shooting style that Gareth has so at any
given point you could be looking in any
direction at anything you have to be
ready we had cranes dollies handheld
drones uh two cameras at the same time
I'm operating the second camera handheld
getting additional angles of a lot of
this action stunts explosions boats real
villagers from the village as extras in
the film I mean it was just such a
puzzle and um really gratifying to
finish shooting it from a physio
physiological standpoint and then also
extremely gratifying to see it cut
together and with all the added video
effects and sound design I mean it's
just such a good sequence yeah stuff all
right yeah and we have the monkey oh
yeah yeah in that sequence which was
that was a highlight for sure everybody
loved the monkey I can understand yes
and everyone seems to like the monkey in
the movie now which is pretty much so
I'm so glad I'm so glad that monkey was
a hoot on set um the animal character
will always win me over the the a brief
story is that the monkey had a trainer
and uh it was he was being trained for
months to do this shot to to trigger the
bomb and the trainer would send us
updates throughout the the filmmaking of
like the progress of the training and
with videos and it would show like the
monkey and there would be captions like
monkey not quite ready like just hasn't
quite got it down yet but by the time we
got to set it was it was another thing
that should be a bonus feature oh 100
the the animal trainer stuff was
hilarious
um but yeah that was that was definitely
the most challenging
um challenge while we're attacking right
there very much all right here's my evil
questions I'm about to ask you to choose
your favorite child and if you could
pick a single frame that you love the
most in this movie blow it up hang it on
the wall which one would you pick and
why actually not a difficult question
for me to answer because I have a
favorite shot in the movie yeah
um it's uh near the end of the film okay
so I maybe don't want to fully
spoil the uh yeah the
um it is a shot of uh a reflection of
Alfie
and it is just such a beautiful moment
and it is the perfect encapsulation of
everything I was talking about because
it was not planned it was one of those
shots that you just you just
accidentally stumble upon and it was
such a little moment of authenticity and
accidental Beauty and incidental beauty
that you couldn't plan for and that's
what makes it so so special what shot
you're talking about is beautiful very
close to the end of the film I lie one
more question before I let you go just
because like one of the the most
exciting things over recent years is you
know I've have fallen in love with
Greg's work and when I hear that he is
mentoring a new cinematographer On The
Rise I get very excited so I kind of
want you to pay it forward now is there
any other cinematographer on the rise
that you know could could be the next
you could be someone that I should Mark
now and then follow their work into the
future yes uh check out Matt bastos
um I think he goes professionally by uh
Mathias which is his full name uh really
great eye really great Instinct
um and uh he's uh New York based for now
but you know a man of the world and he
shot additional photography on story Ave
which is also coming out soon that my
buddy Eric Branco shot
um great film about the Bronx a
beautifully shot and he also has a a
bunch of Indies in the can I think he
has one called gazer that's coming
hitting the festival soon so he he's
very much at that like
has the Indies they're starting to hit
the festivals it's like the first stage
of that but beautiful work beautiful eye
and uh yeah he's one to watch for sure I
love it I love it and again I love your
work so so much it's phenomenal here in
the Creator but fixation and anything
else I've seen you deliver really on
point I cannot wait to see what you do
from here thanks so much I really
appreciate that